along with the return of a must-watch
murder mystery series is a
dracula-centric horror flick another
action movie from a wonderful action
star the final season of a show that has
been money for showtime and everyone's
favorite animated Spidey swinging in
right into your living room on this
week's what to watch my show is hanging
on by a thread here finding this killer
is the only way you'll have a show
I want to make a podcast with me
oh my God this is corny
murder yeah murder him right in the
elevator up to the premiere of its third
season is only murders in the building
before we look ahead to what's coming
it's worth noting that seasons one and
two are both coming in certified fresh
with Tomato Meter scores of 100 and 98
respectively and hey my Insider
knowledge tells me by clicking on the
show page that season three is also
certified fresh so that's the first
reason to get buzzed into this one the
second is that this time around the
building referred to in the title is now
a theater instead of Apartments as this
season's murder will revolve around what
happened to a theater performer played
by the one and only Paul Rudd and
speaking of buildings guess who's
entering this season Merrill as in
Streep she joins the already iconic cast
that includes Selena Gomez and the other
guys whose names are there Martin
just kidding it's Martin Short and Steve
Martin of course
this looks like a
like a buffer to the ship everywhere
evil isn't bored
but if you liked your murders a little
more terrifying pitting feeders is the
horror flick the last Voyage of the
Demeter the first reason to embark on
this one is that it's an adaptation of
the Captain's Log which is a chapter
from Bram Stoker's 1897 novel Little
Women I mean Dracula sorry I got my
notes mixed up and that chapter we
mentioned is the second reason to see
this one as it follows a ship and her
crew heading from Carpathia to London
and countering not only a tough ocean
Voyage but a residence that's also
stalking them aboard the boat what like
bad Seafood oh maybe that maybe that
means Dracula reason three is the sneaky
good cast taking us on this Voyage which
includes Corey Hawkins AKA Dr Dre along
with David dasmolchan who is always
creepy scary and I mean that in a nice
way plus Liam Cunningham who played davo
seaworth on Game of Thrones Miss yadavi
this
directions amazing
arriving on Netflix this week is the new
Gal Gadot action movie Heart of Stone
yup our gal gal is back and she's joined
by Jamie Dornan which is enough star
power to constitute reason number one to
remember your Netflix password Godot
plays an intelligence operative who is
trying to protect a valuable and
dangerous asset on behalf of a global
peacekeeping organization which is just
a wordy way of saying she kicks major
ass which we know she's really good at
and we're excited to see again that's
reason number two to see Heart of Stone
the third is that director Tom Harper
comes in with a pretty impressive resume
that includes the certified fresh the
aeronauts the BBC series War and Peace
and some episodes of Killian Murphy's
awesome show peaky blinders say less the
guy is good
thing that you do now matters in a way
didn't before Chuck Rhodes is paying
attention
we're not waiting to pounce we're gonna
tell you what we're gonna do and then
we're gonna do it
and cashing in for its seventh season is
the Showtime series billions the first
reason to invest in this show is that
not only is this the seventh season but
it will be the last for what has become
Showtime's longest running drama which
brings us to the second reason to tune
into billions the previous six seasons
are all fresh on the Tomato Meter with
four of them certified fresh while it
has carried a strong audience score of
70 along the way too a strong portfolio
as they say in the big money business I
would assume Reason 3 is that one of the
show's original Stars Damien Lewis is
back he left after season five and Corey
Stoll took over as the villain or other
hero depending how you watch it but he
has returned to help bring the show to
the Finish Line you can Bank on it
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
[Music]
and finally Landing in the universe of
VOD is Spider-Man across the
spider-verse the animated flick has been
a monster hit this year coming in
certified fresh at 95 on the Tomato
Meter and banking more than its
predecessor at the global box office
with over
683 million dollars dang Sling It Spidey
if you need another reason to finally
see this one or see it again and again
it's worth noting that there is a third
installment beyond the spider-verse on
the way eventually not to mention a
female focused spin-off about
Spider-Woman so there's plenty to be
invested in and finally if you did catch
this one in theaters what did you miss I
mean this is animation and there are
multiple spider people and spider verses
to soak in you had to have missed a few
things right boom reason three you're
welcome
[Music]
that's how we do slinging five picks to
help you sort through all the murders in
your building figuratively speaking of
course I hope be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you did check out whether it was on this
list or not remember to check out
rottentomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh